the rock yeah you're friends with him
yeah you're friends with the [ __ ]
rock how did your friendship with the
rock happen so during covid I was like I
once things shut down I was like oh
we're not going anywhere for a minute
I'm talking a handful of comics that are
like very bummed as I was we're like oh
man and there's some talk of like it's
cut is stand up even gonna come back I
mean truly there was no sign of of even
the business coming back it was like is
that the end of TV and movies you're
always trying to do these like Zoom
shows some stand-up shows but then like
Zoom TV shows where it was just and I
was like [ __ ] I mean it was such a um
high level of uncertainty and I was like
well I got to control what I can control
which is trying to you know for myself
my own sanity trying to create and put
up more content
do dumb little videos I had a friend
maybe these like little braces I would
do these little characters and then I
did some puppet stuff made some songs
and then I was like I'm just gonna try
to be thinking more in terms of like
just putting up funny stuff so I see um
a post a headline that Gwyneth Paltrow
was selling candles that smell like her
vagina right through her company called
goop right right yeah variety with me on
that one yeah
um and so uh they sold out in like 10
minutes like these candles that smell
like her vagina and I was like whoa and
then um I was and I was like well who's
the male equivalent to that and uh who
would like to like ball scented candles
so I was like oh you know as I posted
the thing and then I just was like and I
never tagged the people but I tagged the
Rock and I was like hey your move man
like [ __ ] they're gonna sell those
like you know equality like you you got
to sell the ball get on that hit up
Yankee Doodle Candle Company whatever
and then I start this is a joke and it
was really just the whole post also just
being like wow like look like how funny
the world we live in where
she made those and they sold out and
people want them it just that was to me
the the bulk of it was like this is
crazy like life is crazy and he
responded and so I started getting all
these messages being like how do you
know the Rock and I was like oh
everybody knows Rock and then I look at
the post and he had commented on it like
brother I've been trying to get you know
uh Boston accounts going but I keep
burning my dick on the wax or something
like and then something else and then he
just made a joke and then and then he
followed me and then we just started
keeping in touch
and then uh
and then he sent me a couple voice notes
saying he'd been following my stuff and
keep at it we'll have some Tara mono
when things resume and life gets back to
normal and then I got the audition for
Vince McMahon and and I was like I don't
know if this came from you but you know
thanks man show looks dope uh very cool
that they're you know you're doing this
um on your story and and how things came
to be and then I went uh out with a
buddy of mine to Chappelle's um uh
summer camp in Ohio where he lives in in
Yellow Springs and uh and I get a and I
had been that point been joking about I
went on like Spade show and a few other
podcasts and I was
Heather's running bit of like the Rocks
ghosting me because I left him my number
in the in the Instagram thing and then I
just hadn't heard from him for like five
months so I was just like yeah they're
actually we had this friendship and now
he's throwing it all away just whatever
it was a fun like thing to joke about
and then I just got a text that says hey
it's DJ The Rock in parentheses let me
know when you get on the phone and I had
been joking about this so I thought
something one of my buddies was [ __ ]
me wait he wants you to call him yeah
were you nervous yeah but I also didn't
think it was him because I was just like
again I've been joking about this so a
buddy of mine is texting me from a
number that's I don't know saying you
know what I'm saying right so then I uh
get a voicemail from him the next day
and then I call him and he goes give me
your best Vince McMahon impression and I
did and I was taking a poo at the time
and uh
I don't know why that was relevant but
it just adds to that that's where you
were that's why I was trying to paint
the picture and then got it and then
we talked like that's really funny
that's good I like that yeah yeah it was
it was and then we just chatted for like
two hours about everything about sports
about comedy about single mom life about
what family stuff about sports about
wrestling crowd work and how he you know
loves these clips I post because he's
like that was my favorite part of doing
it in the ring was like breaking the
fourth wall and going off script he's
like not everybody could do it and I
love to do it and and we started really
diving in on on that aspect of
Performing and it was like we've been
friends for 30 years and I was like man
I should record that whole conversation
put it out as a podcast and uh and then
I even asked him one point I go why
haven't you done I was like you got to
do stand-up we got to do like a young
Rock You Know tour and he was like I
could just come out and he's like but I
want to he's like everyone's got to
write jokes to me they're just like the
worst I want to come out and just bomb I
was like well yeah because if you bomb
you can just pull a shirt down a little
show a little nip everyone will go crazy
you always have a way to save the joke
sure and then he's like uh and he's just
got a comic's brain too he's real quick
filthy but like articulate and and has
like a real respect for the craft but
like a real connection to it which is
why he he uh he loves performing because
he's like the wrestling which I didn't
realize I watched a decent amount of
wrestling growing up but now have
obviously gone back to really uh you
know insert myself in that world and man
like the Showmanship level at a certain
time was like Bonkers I didn't really
appreciate it as a kid like how much to
create these characters but then like
the commitment level is like
pretty high
um but anyway so then we just uh he's
just been cool man and a great story man